hey guys what's up
i wanted to check in
um
i'm in the hospital still you've gotten
some answers
um i'm dealing with
jillian
beret
syndrome so i'm
working through that jenna jameson
shares a health update with fans
revealing she's undergoing treatment for
a rare illness i wanted to let you know
that i see all your dms and i
appreciate it so much on monday the
former adult film star posted that video
from her hospital bed explaining that
doctors have determined she's dealing
with guillain-barre syndrome a rare
autoimmune disorder that affects the
body's nerves and muscles
i'm getting my second
ivig
and i just watched my videos that i put
up and i realized that i totally
mispronounced
what's going on with me it's called
guillaume beret syndrome that's like how
new the diagnosis is in the caption
jenna says she started an ivig treatment
adding that she will most likely stay in
the hospital until her treatment is
complete as for those who think she
developed gbs as a result of getting the
kovid 19 vaccine the 47 year old mom of
three insists she quote did not get the
jab or any jab this is not a reaction to
the jab according to reports from yale
medicine published on december 17th
there are about 100 suspected cases of
gbs that have been identified among 12.8
million people who have received the
johnson and johnson covid19 vaccine but
back to jenna according to the timeline
presented in her post monday marks her
fifth day in the hospital and on
saturday jenna's partner leor bitten
posted a video to instagram updating
fans on her condition and what led to
her hospitalization she's not feeling so
good
she was actually throwing up for a
couple weeks and
we had to take her to the hospital he
went on to explain that the hospital
gave her a ct scan and cleared her to
return home but things quickly got worse
she came back home she couldn't carry
herself her muscles in her
legs were very weak so
she wasn't able to walk to the bathroom
she was falling on the way
back or to the bathroom and then i would
have to pick her up and put her in bed
and then eat within two days it got
really
uh
not so good her legs started to
not older
she couldn't she wasn't able to walk
lior says even with a walker she wasn't
able to hold up her own body weight she
collapsed her
her knees kind of buckled
so she wasn't able to hold her
body weight
so
i decided
she needs to go to the hospital
according to the cdc guillain-barre
syndrome affects around one in 100 000
people and is a rare autoimmune disorder
in which a person's own immune system
damages the nerves causing muscle
weakness and sometimes paralysis the
disorder can cause symptoms that persist
for a few weeks to several years and the
cdc says that most people recover fully
but some have had permanent nerve damage
and in rare cases people have died as
for jenna she says she's just focused on
getting healthy so i just
had
an infusion
and um
we're just working towards getting
better